So I'm going to use my little friend on the right.
>> Yeah, the quick access menu.
>> I haven't used him in a while.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> That's nice. Okay. new field.
>> Exactly.
>> because the object already exists. It's a relationship.
>> It's a relationship, and it's going to be a lookup. And, mainly because
you can't actually do a master detail to a user object, that's just one
of the requirements in sales force. But also, we already have all of those
records created, so we couldn't even do a master detail if we wanted to.
>> Okay, so, it's related to, user.
>> Right.
>> And, of course, the next ritual.
>> So, you want to change that to say Stage Manager instead of User.
>> Okay, that makes sense. Okay, so we've added our user field.
>> Right there, yeah, sweet. Stage manager, look up to the user. Great.
>> Cool.
>> So, let's go back to the Udacity stage and make you the manager.
>> Yeah! OK, Udacity stage.
>> So there's the Stage Manager field, you can just double-click it.
>> Okay, so, I can double-click here. Use my magnifying glass friend.
>> Sweet.
>> And, it already knows, I'm a user. That's, that's creepy Sam. I
don't like when, Sales force creeps me out. How do they know that?
>> Well, you're the logged in user right now, and you're
the only user in your organization because you just created it today.
>> Okay. And I don't have a role, but presumably I could. Okay.
Save.
>> Yeah. And we even could have created a filter to
only show people by certain roles to show up in this lookup.
>> Cool. Okay. So, we've done it.
>> Great.
>> I'm managing stages.
>> You're the manager of the stages now.
[LAUGH].